let's now go to the lack of Charisma of
Ron DeSantis and we're not going to
spend a ton of time on this Ron DeSantis
was interviewed a couple nights ago by
Jesse Waters Jesse Waters is a Fox News
host who I I'm aware that he now is
going to be in Prime Time on Fox news
thanks to the firing of Tucker Carlson
and a sort of reorganization that went
on
um and Jesse Waters is horrible
but Ron DeSantis is so painfully awkward
and cringy here is DeSantis claiming the
left doesn't want people to be happy
and he's not really making a very good
case that that's the truth and after
ovens why does the government do that if
they just want to control you have an
itch on the left they want to control
Behavior a lot we saw the same thing
with covet a lot of that wasn't about
your health it was about they wanted to
control your behavior so they just don't
want people to be happy and be able to
make their own decisions they were going
after gas stoves in Florida we made them
tax-free we may have to do some
incentives for for the Coal Fire Pizza
because you know what uh we'll take it
they're going to want us to microwave
this pizza so you're wrong okay and
there's Ron DeSantis eating pizza eating
pizza you know you're really angering
liberals when you eat pizza on Fox news
from a studio in New York City this is
supposed to make the guy likable in some
way this is supposed to show us that
he's right on some policy issue it is
just pathetic then the topic by the way
of Gavin Newsom came up came uh came up
and Gavin Newsom is the Democratic
governor of California who has been
trolling DeSantis very hard very hard
and DeSantis actually has to lie to
criticize California which they love to
do what's with Gavin Newsom
well you know I was born and raised in
Florida I never saw a California license
plate my whole life in Florida and why
would you why would I now I know people
are going to write to me and say David
what is wrong with Ron DeSantis why why
does his head shake like that I am going
to remind everybody to our knowledge Ron
DeSantis does not have a condition that
would cause any kind of shaking or
Tremors uh nothing parkinsonian he
doesn't have tardive dyskinesia or any
of that if he did we would not be
pointing this out this is a move that
Rhonda santis does to seem engaging and
laid back he just his his head moves
like a bobble head and he could float on
out of the screen if you're not careful
it's a very weird trait and he needs he
needs some kind of a personality
transplant Trump was right believe a San
Diego or or uh Los Angeles and yet since
I've been Governor we've seen a huge
rush of people moving clear across the
country to leave California leave San
Francisco Lee Valley to come to Florida
nobody no California had never lost
population for its entire history lie
okay so that's not true and again it's
like States sometimes gain population
sometimes they lose it can happen for a
number of different reasons it doesn't
have to be because of awoke dystopia or
whatever the case may be but
there were multiple years in the 90s
when California lost population he's
hanging his hat on this is a new thing
it's not true until he became governor
and so I think he sees people leaving I
think he sees that there's deterioration
and I think he's lashing out do you
think Newsom is trying to be next in
line and jump Kamala Harris well you
know what I told him is stop messing
around on the sidelines like either do
it or not like are you going to take on
Joe if so step into the ring and do it
and so I think he's kind of maneuvering
in the in the background but you know
that would be interesting to see if
Biden doesn't ultimately make it uh how
that resolves it do you think Biden is
going to make it
look I think that people want to move on
from Biden I think that's very very
clear I don't know if he's going to get
that message and so he may very well try
to stick it out we'll be ready for for
whoever because I think the thing about
the Democrat Party is yeah Biden's got
huge problems we all know that but we
talk about this corruption what does he
have going for him Harris is his
impeachment insurance no matter what
Biden does nobody wants Harris and so
it's almost like just let him finish
shouting by the way let him finish
rather than impeaching wouldn't it be
good for there to be something to
impeach Joe Biden over descend is like a
matter of political strategy I don't
know that impeaching it makes sense how
about is there any reason to impeach him
it's sort of like the stuff with the
crimes does it matter that there's no
evidence of criminality nor charges nor
an indictment or no it's just like do we
want to charge him or not is really all
that matters at this point with these
people so DeSantis just making very
little sense and I'll be honest I don't
know who DeSantis actually is getting
any traction with it's certainly not the
broader Republican electorate in when he
goes to a diner it's extremely awkward I
don't know who likes DeSantis here
actually there's a woman that goes to my
gym who's been wearing a DeSantis tank
top for a while so I I guess I could ask
her
um here is DeSantis weighing in on the
Loyalty question that Donald Trump has
brought up so many times Trump says
you're disloyal do you feel that way
disloyal to who I mean you know
politicians have to earn support they're
not entitled to support I did a lot for
him in 2016 and 2020 by the way I was
happy to do it oh yeah but at the end of
the day
um you know I'm loyal to my family to
our Constitution and to the good Lord
and I have a vision I think I'm the guy
that can beat Biden but even more
importantly no more excuses on these
issues I'm gonna get all of this stuff
done we'll have a plan on day one to get
going and get cracking and give you two
great terms for eight years and really
get the country on a fundamentally
different path I think I'm the guy to do
it and so I have uh the responsibility
to step up and serve there you go and
you can really feel the energy and the
enthusiasm and the fact that DeSantis
really is going to get all of these
things done isn't he you can really just
tell so listen it's the entire loyalty
thing
um there these are both clowns when it
comes to loyalty I'm talking about Trump
and scientist Trump's view is DeSantis
isn't loyal because he decided to run
against Trump after Trump supported him
this is politics okay let's pull up our
big boy pants and let's realize that
this is politics this isn't uh you know
it's not gin rummy or whatever
um this is this is just kind of the way
it is and if you're going to be this
much of a snowflake Trump I'm talking
about it's going to be tough to have
success in other areas and Trump is of
course struggling for Success from the
point of view of DeSantis the idea of
invoking God and saying my loyalty is to
God rather than to Trump again it's I
know it's a small thing but it's another
one of these examples of how they
constantly have to drag in religion
to civil government positions he's
running for a position in civil
government should have nothing to do
whatsoever with God but he just can't
resist
one of our sponsors today is replace
your mortgage mortgages are a really
interesting thing in the United States
the poor often can't afford them and the
rich often don't use them instead the
wealthy use special Financial tools to
pay off their debts often in a fraction
of the time that it takes for a
middle-class American to realize that
same payoff replace your mortgage
teaches you how you can pay off your
home in five to seven years without
needing to make more money than you're
currently making right now and in
addition they can teach you how to
better utilize your existing assets and
Equity to beginner continue growing
wealth and passive income through
additional strategies and they actually
have an upcoming Workshop that will show
you how you can take advantage of these
strategies how it all works create your
own economy in a sense you can go to
replace your universe city.com slash
Pacman to watch the interview I did with
their founder Michael Lush to learn how
you can get exclusive access to what can
be a life-changing virtual event the
link is in the description